- La formule fait du bien.
- On voit enfin la lumière
au bout du tun
- Hélas, ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'on l'entend.
La différence cette fois,
c'est le variant Omicron.
Selon le premier ministre,
il est moins virulent et nous
permet d'espérer que le pire
sera bientôt derrirerere-nous.
- Le nombre d'infections,
le nombre de cas se stabilise,
et selon les experts,
on a atteint, il y a quelques
jours, un pic.
- Ce qui permet au gouvernement
de diminuer la pression.
d d d d le couvre-feu :
il sera levé dès lundi.
Le premier ministre l'avait
sésésésé la veille du jour
de l'an, en raison
de l'explosion des cas.
- Il y aura un couvre-fe
C'est un geste qui est extrême
parce que la situation est
extrême.
- Mais même si les hopitaux sont
toujours débordés, il estime que
la mesure n'est plus nécessaire.
(cris d'enfants)
E : : : : la rentrée scolaire.
La santé publique ne croit pas
que le retour en classe soit
trop risqué même si on s'attend
à des ratés.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS ROBERGE,
ministre de l'Éducation, Québec
- Ça ne sera pas parfait,
les prochaines semaines vont
nécessiter des ajustements.
- Le ministre de l'Éducation
misera notamment sur les tests
rapides pour contrôler
la transmission du virus.
3,6 millions d'entre eux seront
distribués dès la semaine
prochaine dans les écoles
et un plan de contingence
est en place.
- On ne demande pas aux parents
de devenir des enseignants
ni de devenir des supp
il est possible que de manière
exceptionnelle, en dernier
recours, temporairement,
- Mais il y a un groupe
n'est pas près de sabrer le
champagne : les non-vaccinés.
Dès le 24 janvier, ils devront
présenter leur pas
vaccinal dans les magasins
de grande surface de plus
de 1500 mètres carrés,
qui ne sont pas spécialisés
en alimentation.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre Santé
et des Services sociaux, Québec
- Ce qu'on ne voulait pas,
surtout, c'eetetetetetette
exigence-là, comme l'a dit le
premier ministre, pour les plus
petits commerces.
- La mise à l'épreuve n'a donc
pas tard n n n n n nouveau
patron de la Santé publique.
Il est arrivé il y a deux jours
et déjà, Luc Boileau impose
un nouveau régime sanitaire
au Québec.
Dr LUC BOILEAU, dir. national
santé publique Qc. par intérim
- Moi, je me sens très à l'aise
avec les recommandations qui ont
été faites, mes opinons ont été
visiblement tenues en compte.
- Les propriétaires de
restaurants, de cinéma et de
salles de spectacles devront
patienter encore un peu.
Il est encore trop tôt pour
permettre leur réouverture
selon la santé publique dont
la priorité est touj
protéger le réseau de la santé.
Mais la situaton pourrait
changer rapidement,
promet le premier ministre.
Ici Alex Boissonneault,
Radio-Canad